foreign
[Music]
but I'd regret it every single day if I
didn't ask you to stay here so we could
try and figure this out together what if
you don't come back I'm gonna come back
you could also totally die I wanna
totally die um
I don't know why why because the fact of
the matter is I'm uncallable I'm not
done because I have something worth
living for now or something you're
fighting for and that is you
[Music]
have you been standing there this whole
time
yes
it seems like you are an emotion God
after all
come with me
I have something you might need
I want to teach you something
I haven't even told my sons
I have a lot of stats
Thunderbolt can't be anything
Thunderbird it's just electricity you
can have it anytime you call power is
everywhere you just have to harness it
now you burnt
thank you
[Music]
power comes from the heart like the
Romans say April quarry a open your
heart
[Music]
open your heart
yes
identity is at the edge of space
you go
and you go until you can't go no further
there you will find the altar of
Eternity Thunderbolt will take you there
you sure you won't come with us we can
really use the king of the Gods no no no
no
to go there
you must be pure
Zeus is many things but he's not pure
foreign
good to go
yeah
how are we getting
[Applause]
your Khan you have finally joined our
fight well if they say better late than
not at all
it's very nice
as you know we used to live in a
peaceful Lots but in our gods were
murdered murdered and now our sacred
Temple has been left unguarded and
hopeless disorders the control of its
power it's just our most sacred Shrine
and it desperate not for long
tell them what happened here today some
of the time that four
drag tag Motley Crew Misfit Desperados
found the tide in the battle that that's
their names in history the odds may be
against us but I'll tell you this for
free haircuts
and here
boy
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Judy Foster Jane Foster The One That Got
Away the one that got away that means
escaped yeah yeah must be hard for you
to see your ex-girlfriend and your ex
hammer hanging out and getting on so
well
[Music]
hey there you are hey I was just calling
you
they're in the shadow realm how'd you
know the atmosphere there has a Darkness
like no other this is if color feels to
tread it's unmistakable
well then if it's color we need
the rainbow foreign
[Music]
oh
hello Guardians what's up buddy can you
open your eyes my superhero in days are
over
great
[Music]
hey guys guys guys guys guys guys I hate
to break up whatever the hell this is
but listen we need your help to win the
battle I am hoping win the battle at
this purposely will drag him down
do nothing just me yes in many he loves
perish he feels their blood is on his
hand all right you know what fine you
sit here let's go
this way they'll make a statue of me
when I save the planet
you stay there and don't be a hero
right hold on
[Music]
it wouldn't hurt to go and help those
innocent people down there
let's get to it shall we
all right
okay come on climb aboard
come on people are dying
okay you won
here we go I'm still break up
okay count three jump one two three
sometimes it just doesn't want to work
off
yeah
you're wasting time come
[Music]
on
hey crew what isn't this beautiful what
is that glorious Aroma I think it's all
the bodies no no no it's wonderful I
remember when we first arrived here just
a bunch of foolish kids really what did
I tell you
well you said we were going on a
vacation to indigaria it was beautiful
the sunrise you mentioned nothing about
it spinning off into chaos and utter
pain pain
I hope you feel better
[Applause]
how are you uh yeah I'm good bro great
look at this guy sleeping on the job are
we lazy bones he's dead
you have got to get us out of here
remember when you told us that this was
going to be a safe vacation I said are
you certain you said oh yeah 100 out of
a thousand percent
[Music]
oh he's still my Rocky heart just take
it in this is absolutely gorgeous thank
you oh what are you doing here we don't
like strangers here in omnipotent City
great great we seek an audience with
Zeus views these use Zeus oh so he does
have a second name well I think I
consideration because
he's my father
and I'm his youngest son die nice we
need to speak to him about the God
butcher the prosciutto man no a maniac
that's been killing Gods wow boring I'm
off to Aphrodite's for pre-drinks she's
an insufferable cow but she's got the
good stuff and then we're all going to
the golden temple for Daddy's great
godly brujah not even telling you this
let's go come on
great great it's the Golden Temple
[Music]
there's a maniac who seeks to end us all
and putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed yes
we've got Korg he's my best friend yes
there's my ex-girlfriend Jay
Valkyrie this is the best game
the Guardians
and giant goats look at those they are
wonderful yes they are they also scream
quite a lot
[Music]
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
it was going to be like a relaxing
holiday
[Music]